hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar interrogating 3d steroids versus
2d monolayer cell models and drug
discovery using cell health microplate
assays i am michelle ashton of laberd's
and I'll be your moderator for today's
events today's educational web seminar
is presented by lab roots and brought to
you by thermo Fisher Scientific to learn
more about our sponsor please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor active we
encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and anytime you want to turn this
presentation to do so simply type them
into the ask a question box click send
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
presentations click on the sports have
found at the top right of the
presentation window this presentation is
educational and must offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process to obtain
your credit
I now present today's speakers dr. Ari
Ari
fire arrow senior scientist at Thermo
Fisher Scientific and dr. Leticia
Montoya scientist cell biology at Thermo
Fisher Scientific for a complete
biography on our speakers please visit
the biography tab at the top of your
screen our speakers will now begin their
presentations
well thank you so much Michelle for the
introduction my name is Annette ephod
and along with my collegues my colleague
Leticia Montoya we are going to be
presenting today a number of results
that would reveal to you what are the
main critical points that you have to be
taken into account when when you are
transitioning between 2d and 3d cellular
models and especially when you are
utilizing cell health
microplate si so we are going to focus
today in trying to reveal to you what
are the critical points that you should
be taking into account the presentation
would be divided into two part so during
the first part of the presentation I
will be discussing with you guys
several key issues that has to be taken
into account when performing this kind
of side-by-side comparison and simply
when when moving from one fellow
assistant through to the other one
between 2d and 3d systems and I'm going
to give you an overview of all the
available products and instruments that
Thermo Fisher Scientific has your
disposal to facilitate this this
transitioning and then we are going to
focus on some of these theoretical
aspects that are really important to be
able to integrate cellular health in 3d
so what are the critical issues what
what would be important to make sure how
such measurements should be performed
especially when utilizing micro
predators and then my colleague Leticia
will will go over to three different
cases of cell health essays that have
been developed originally for 2d semi
systems in by thermo Fisher Scientific
but we are hoping now that we can
demonstrate you guys how those systems
can be utilized also on 3d we are going
to show you results that will illustrate
both endpoint and kinetic essence and
then but last but not least we are going
to give you some ideas and really
showcase how this quantitative approach
utilizing micro great readers can be
really very well correlated with the
results that can be obtained with high
quantum high content emission hopefully
after this hour of discussing with you
guys and giving
giving you our shot then you will be
able to learn some important messages
and be able to really take those
messages and facilitate your work out in
the future so I like to start today by
going over through something that is
probably quite familiar for you all and
it relates to the pipeline of drug
discovery we we all know that that the
pipeline of from discovery is
characterized by the quite strong
emphasis on throughput at the very early
stages of the drug discovery process at
the very least early stages of the drug
discovery process scientists are
interested in really generating a large
amount of promising leads that can be
then further developed into promising
drug candidates
so for these Hydrabad analyzers are the
very early stages we we have
traditionally utilized in vitro assays
and that has been routinely performed
included and the reason why they have
been informing to this because such
models are extremely user-friendly from
the perspective of the throughput so if
they are very simple models and they are
very easily adaptable to hydraboost
screening conditions however the main
detriment or the main drawback of such
model is that they are really restricted
simplicity and the fact that they often
lack on predictive capacity so in an
attempt to really improve this quality
of the individual screens that are
perform at the early stage of the drug
discovery process so there has been a
progressive shift towards the
utilization of 3d Simo systems and this
is perhaps a good moment for you guys
for us to clarify that often in the
literature we talk about 2d and 3d but
we are in both cases talking about cells
and they of course they they are all in
3d they exist as in 3d but when we talk
about 2d we talk about adherent or
suspended cells and they are
dramatically different from the cells
that are growing in a more geometrically
structure shape that we will shoulder
discuss afterwards for the purpose of
this presentation every time that we
talk about
Toodee we refer to monolayer semi
monolayers and every time that we talk
about treaty we are focusing on on
thyroid so really the fact that with
with ferrets we can still maintain a
very high throughput while gaining
valuable complexity it really what has
prompted an explosion of 3d studies you
can see at the moment more quite close
to 1000 peer-reviewed publications
polish every year on the topic of 3d and
and what this is the reason why we are
discussing today about 3d we are trying
to aid this transition we are trying to
help you guys using new tools that can
be utilized for this transition so the
question that I want to tackle now at
the mall next is why do we believe that
these 3d systems are actually better
models why do we believe that this added
complexity actually increases the
predictability value of those systems
and and really the main feature that
it's very relevant to indicate for for
steroids in general for 3d models is
that they really are better for
mycological motors and there's been an
increasing amount of errors showing
showing that you get much better
pharmacological predictive
predictability with this 3d cell the the
main reason behind that is simply that
when 3d cells are formed and when
Pharaoh itself form you you end up with
an ecosystem of cells that are
interacting with each other in such a
way that really resembles much better
what happens in be especially in the
case of solid tumors so 3 T cells and
specialist ferret have become much
better much more advantageous models for
pharmacology pharmacological prediction
of drugs in solid tumors they are better
models of in vivo hypoxia they are
better models also this in vivo
internationally that is typical of
tumors and you can really study the
effects of drugs in a much more valuable
way a much more meaningful way that we
could in the traditional to to the mono
layers that have been utilized in drug
discovery
so as we move from 2d to 3d we we often
encounter scientists that are developing
new 3d systems but when developing these
new 3d systems they they are often in
this in this in this situation that they
need to utilize or they need to
interrogate cellular health functions
and they are unable to find the tools
that can be utilized simultaneously in
2d and 3d models the truth is as you can
see in this conversion table that the
minority of the commercial and even in
house let's say workflows that exist
currently they are built around 2d
cultures and scientists are faced with
the situation that they they just don't
have enough to especially commercial
tools that can be utilized readily from
2d to 3d so so this is a situation that
we are trying to tackle and that we are
trying to address here at some official
scientific so our R&D scientists are
trying to validate better tools and we
are trying to really address the lack of
these validated essays so this is
precisely what we are going to try to
illustrate to you guys today we are
going to start with the current
portfolio of products that we have to
support 3d cellular models I'm I must
mention also at this stage that we're
not going to discuss today anything
related to how 3d cell cultures are
grown on how they are formed we are only
focusing on how to integrate 3d server
functions once these 3 T cells or
traditional systems have been developed
but it's good for you guys to be aware
that we offer a very broad portfolio of
products that includes
cells that also includes mattresses on
cell cultural vessels and especially in
the case of couple of free 3d systems
thermo Fisher has developed this fara
portfolio of products that covers a
number of different cell culture dishes
and circle vessels that are all that
have ultra low attachment surface and
this is precisely this is fara
microplates are the ones that we are
going to be showing today in
in our result we also have a number of
media and supplements that can be
utilized for for growing cells in 3d and
last but not least we have a number of
instruments and essays on V agents that
can be utilized to study several
functions in 3d and those are the ones
that we are going to be focusing on the
presentation today but as I said we are
here to help you so if you have any
questions about any of these products
that you have seen during this
presentation please reach out to us and
if we cannot answer the question right
away then we will be happy to put you in
contact with one of our specialists so
when we talk about approaches that have
been utilized to study 3d once it's very
very often the case that we see we see
researchers researchers utilizing high
content emission and fluorescent imaging
those have been traditionally used for
exploring 3d 3d morphology for studying
3d phenotypic changes but now more and
more realistic scientist interested in
exploring similar function and
quantifying some of function using
microwave microcomputers this is
actually a logical approach we feel that
it's it's it would it's for scientists
it's microplate readers are nearly in
every lab in every life science lab so
it is it's very very useful shift to be
able to continue using a machine but
also being able to progressively adapt
more and more cellular assays that are
so widely available for 2d models into
the 3d models space so today we are
going to focus on quantification of
silver function using micro plate
readers and then the micro paper that is
our heroes today it's the thermal
scientific body scan Lux multimode
microplate reader which was launched in
2015 and it is really a multi technology
instrument that can be used for
measuring of Segen signals in basically
any kind of microwave format from 6 to
1536 of well plates
we are shortly going to be going over
these detection technologies but I want
to point out that the virus can lock is
a micro penetrator that
allows you to perform essays in endpoint
and kinetic mode which we will be
covering today but we can also or you
can also perform experiments in the
spectral multi point on Connecticut's
spectral mode these are typically
available mode for all smoke all of them
all of the micro plate readers that are
available in the market so even though I
will be featuring often to virus can LOX
multi mode readers today most of the
theoretical assumptions that we are
going to be discussing a lot of
theoretical critical points that you
have to be aware of they would also be
applicable to other multimode microwave
readers and last but not least one
important feature that I want to bring
to your attention I when it when it
comes about the body scan box is that
virus can lock is operated with a free
software it's called Kennedy software
and we didn't kind of software every
user has access to an extensive protocol
library the scan it cloud protocol
library which currently contains over
130 sessions and some of the others that
we will discuss be discussing today are
included in this protocol library every
single protocol library every single
critical essay in the library has real
data with real results with real death
analyzes and it's not really curated
data so our scientists make the same
mistakes then that users know that the
[ __ ] is - so we we have wanted to keep
it as authentic and genuine as we
possibly can so you will find their real
representative data and and you will be
able to really analyze that data and and
explore that data to learn about the
usage of our instruments and our
software so so now I I said that we will
now talk a little bit about the
technologies that can be read with micro
page readers this is something very
broadly presented even though I'm
referring to body scan locks so the
mayority of the multi mode readers that
are available for scientists they are
able to measure optical signals that are
mostly absorbance or presence and
luminescence virus catalogs can also
measure on a special type of
fluorescence that is called
time-resolved fluorescence or TRF and we
can also measure
our special technology that that is a
cool alpha screen today we are going to
be focusing on the two most widely used
technologies or at least two of the most
widely used technologies and that is
absorbent and fluorescence measurements
and when we talk about these two
different detection technologies it is
very very common the case that
scientists really get worried about the
possible differences in the detection
between 2d and 3d silver models and they
often get intrigued about the fact that
they don't know how to select which is
the best possible measurement mode that
they could utilize with their samples so
we are going to try to briefly touch
upon the critical things that have to be
taken into account when performance
either absorbance or a fluorescence
intensity measurements I start with a
very simple conversion between
absorbance or that is also called
photometry and for essence measurement
and bear with me I know that many of you
are familiar with these technologies I
just want to give you a very brief
overview so that you can understand why
this the way in the ticket but the way
that the technology works really
influences the way that our instruments
are designed and in general most
micrograph readers are designed so when
we talk about photometric measurements
or absorbance measurements we meant we
are interested in measuring absorption
of light so to be able to measure
absorption of light samples need to be
illuminated at the very specific
wavelength where they have the maximum
of observance and the instruments simply
record are measured the light intensity
that comes out of the sample so for the
purpose of performing absorbance
measurement
we have a wavelength separation step
that happens before the sample is
illuminated and then we we are recording
all the line that goes through the
sample so in most micro predators that
are able to measure photometry you
always have a detector and a lamp that
are located in opposite sides of the
plate in the case of high risk unlocks
we are eliminating the samples from the
top and then measuring from the bottom
of the plate but the sample has to be
illuminated all the way through to be
able
measured absorbance or to be able to
record a photometric measurement this is
a slightly different situation in
fluorescence in fluorescence compounds
are also illuminate those samples are
also illuminated at a very specific
wavelength the same way that we do in
absorbance measurements but in the case
of fluorescence measurements as you are
aware the molecules that are having
fluorescent properties they go into an
excited state and an after that excited
States there is a return to return to
the ground state that it's coupled with
the emission of light and that emission
of light happens at a very specific
wavelength so in the case of the
recording of fluorescence or the
detection of fluorescence with
microwaves readers there is always a
wavelength separation that happens
before the light hits the sample before
the sample is illuminated and then after
the sample it's illuminated so that you
are able to record the specific
immediately signal that that takes place
at that specific excitation light most
of the my creditors that are out there
can do that in two different ways they
can record the fluorescence that is
generated from the top of the plate and
they can also record the fluorescence
that is generated from the bottom of the
plate and this makes a kind of a big
distinction on the way that we can also
measure 2d versus 3d so what is critical
to consider in the case of Epsilon's
when comparing to the vs 3d so I already
mentioned that absorbance measurements
are always performed through the well
and when my competitors detect the
delight the intensity of the light that
comes our example they really cannot
make a distinction in the on the nature
of the absorption process that took
place on the sample and what we know is
that really the decrease on the light
intensity that we measured with
microplate readers can because mostly by
the light absorbance that is on the
sample but it also can happen due to the
light scattering of the sample and that
is that sample can really deviate the
angle into which the delight it's
actually illuminating the sample so a
set we cannot discriminate microwave
spectrophotometers cannot discriminate
between the
two processes and they had really
different processes as you can see in
this scheme that it's here located in
the right part of the slide during that
during the scattering process particles
that are on the sample are really on
scattering light they are deviating the
path of the light and because of because
of this nature of this process because
of the fact that we are deviating the
path of the light then this scattering
process is strongly dependent on the
distance that exists between the sample
and the detector so if we go back to the
to this scheme to the left where you see
the differences between 2d and 3d it can
now become a little bit more obvious for
you guys that if we are comparing 2d
version sweetie you are going to have a
different contribute contribution of the
scheduling process into D versus 3d
because the distance that exists between
the sample and the detector will be
different in the case of 2d versus 3d so
an important consideration that you have
to make when performing absorbance
measurements in Somis measuring
measurements in 2d versus Tweety is that
you have to include controls without the
dyes that can be utilized to exclude
this scattering process and really if
you see biggest really big differences
taking place in 2d versus 3d
scattering might be one of the reasons
as to why this will play out we know
what Boris Kahn locks that the distance
is still between detector and sample are
pretty small and and very small
scattering angles will not have an
impact they will still be detected by
the detector so we know that you know in
our instrument in vertical locks this
this is having still a minimal impact
but if you are using all the kinds of
micrometers this is definitely one
aspect that has to be taken into account
when performing absorbance measurements
readout so then in the case of
fluorescence intensity measurement
fluorescent intensity measurements as we
discussed some some minutes ago they can
be performed typically in two different
ways they can be performed from the top
or they can be performed from the from
the bottom in the case of the top
readouts
these top fluorescent measurements are
ideally suited suited to to measure self
resistance otherwise call us biochemical
assays you can see here in the in this
first scheme that the the optical path
of various conne locks which is kind of
shown here with these lines on double
lines it always have this double conical
shape and in the case of IRIScan locks
the focal point has been designed in
such a way that it it hits the sample
right in the middle of the solution so
when you're measuring samples that are
almost with that that have fluorescence
machine easily disputed on the well then
this is an idea optical design that will
allow you to excite and measured the the
most of the emitted signals from the
middle of the well a situation is
slightly different when we talk about
bottom villainville so what on reading
measuring bottom reading measurements
are generally ideal for 2d cells
especially if the fluorescence is
generated inside of the cells and that
is because in the gates of photon
reading and then again I'm referring to
where it's unlocked but it's a situation
that is very similar about between
different manufacturers so then in that
case the optical beam has a focal point
that is exactly on the bottom of the
world so exactly in the place where 2d
cells are adhering and where the most of
the fluorescence will be located in
indication cell based assays so when
comparing top reading and bottom reading
it is very generally a film that top
reading is ideal for self reassess or
biochemical assays and then bottom
feeding is idea for 2d cells or or mono
layer symbol monitors but then what
happens with 3d sources and we we
treated cells we fall into this kind of
intermediate situation we have few cells
and the the fluorescent is often
restricted to the vicinity of the cells
where the fluorescent probe is actually
in but we also have self drying
solutions that are in the case of
Pharaohs that they are sort of floating
in the middle of the well so what's
using that case it's clearly that bottom
really might not be ideal in that
situation but would top reading then
before
efficient to measure the fluorescence
associated to this ferrous to this
geometrical structure well the answer to
that question of what we have found out
in our studies is that so fluorescent
can be sufficient for a tree itself but
it clearly depends on the SI and this
probably needs to be optimized for every
single si so if your microwave heater
has soap and water reading so very
recommended thing to do is that you
would compare the performance between
top and bottom reading we also have
found out that when using multi moment
refrigerators it is often recommended
that one would utilize selectable
excitation bandwidth typically
micro-grant readers have the possibility
to switch between different excitation
bandwidth and by switching between
different excitation bandwidth you would
actually have would increase the beam
diameter and would therefore increase
volume that is illuminated and excited
on the on the sample so here you see and
what actually happens this is some
hematocrit personation but get the point
that when you are switching between five
nanometers to 12 millimeters in the case
of forests and locks you can
dramatically increase in in this case it
actually increases from zero point seven
millimeters to two millimeters so it
really dramatically dramatically
increases the excited cellular volume
and therefore it increases the
likelihood that you will be able to
excite the cells that are located within
the steroids
so it's check of recommendation for you
guys is that if you are able to utilize
top fluorescence then it would be
recommended to use longer exam
higher excitation bandwidth so that you
can excite a large amount of the cellar
volume at this point I want to also make
a clarification because this is also a
question that is often asked to us that
it is true that by increasing the
excitation bandwidth using top optics
you will also end up in often you will
also end up increasing them the
background fluorescence but hopefully
this is something that can be taken care
of and often the increase in the
background signal will not be so high
that it would affect the measurement so
you will still be gaining higher signal
by increasing the
excitation bandwidth but we come also
across these kind of situations when
when scientists are comparing 2d vs. 3d
and it it's often the case that they are
bound to use both and fluorescence
because it's simply optimal for the cell
health si that they have chosen and in
if that is the case then you have to be
aware that there are differences on the
way that bottom fluorescence is measured
in 2d versus 3d so when using to the
system to the solar system it is
typically the case that cells are grown
in flood bottom plates and when bottom
fluorescent is selected in multi mode
readers and in particular in virus and
locks so scientists tend to collect
these measurements using multi points so
make the measurements are performed in
different locations on the bottom of the
world and and you can see as you can as
you can visualize in this slide you can
get very nice heat maps of the thermal
distribution on the bottom of the well
however if you choose to utilize these
kind of multi point measurements for
bottom fluorescence readout in 2d cells
you have to be aware that such type of
measurements are not possible to perform
with treaty cells simply because if you
are using on a scope of free system as
the one that we are utilizing the
sparrow microplates
they are shapes they have you shaped you
bottom and in that in those cases it's
not really possible to to to have an
even illumination of the of the well
button so only the center point location
can be measured on those cases that can
result in very different signals so it
would be recommendable in that case to
compare only the bottom points in both
2d versus 3d here we have an example of
what kind of impact this can actually
have this comes from our own results and
and you can see here the measurement
performed in 2d versus 3d with a rhythm
with a diet that binds to the living
cells on the bottom of the world and
what what they impact that we can see in
this case is that the signal that is
recorded in 3d is higher than the signal
that is recorded in 2d and it's not
really because there would be
amount of cells that are living on the
treaty system is simply because the
background that is measured when using
multi points across the entire bottom of
the world is higher than the one that is
measured only on the on the middle of
the well indicates of the spirits so
please be aware that when you are
comparing to the universe's treaty
treaty it is really important to select
comparable patterns in the case of
portal reading so that if you are bound
to use important reading then be be sure
that that you are comparing same kind of
areas same kind of excited volumes in 2d
versus 3d otherwise your results are
going to be impacted by this so now
we've got two all of the most important
theoretical aspects that needs to be
taken into account when it comes to
microwave reading and I will I will
continue by introducing the cell health
essays that we are going to be
discussing today so you are also very
familiar with this sort of a scheme that
is presented here ourselves are moving
from a Bible to a non-viable state they
go through a number of different
morphological and functional changes and
we know that in pre little cells for
example cells have an author metabolism
they also have these regulated cellular
proliferation very low ATP values and
all of these functional changes can be
actually follow with a number of
different cell cell health essays when
they continue to today I am move to a
non-viable state then then as you can
see us on the skin then other cellular
events kicked in for example then we
have membrane permeability changes and
we have apoptosis proteins being
released and then apoptosis events being
triggered and also for those changes we
have there have been a number of cell
health as I said has been developed in
our presentation today we are going to
focus on three cellular assays that are
targeting metabolic studies metabolic
changes cellular metabolic changes and
DNA content you can see here that we are
going to be talking about Taekwon
ecstasy
press the blue ashes which are both
cellular redox die and then we are going
to be talking about the very specific
dye that is used for quantification of
DNA contents icons direct and and then
before I go I want to also introduce you
guys to the silver model that we are
going to be discussing today so the
silver model that we are going to be
talking about is the a5 4 9 non-steroid
model it's a hydric good I would say
low complexity model we we are using we
are using it because it's really an
excellent model it has been extensively
used for no model non-small cell lung
cancer model especially for the
adenocarcinoma type and it's really easy
to set up when starting to perform 3d
studies we have as I already mentioned
grown B cells in ultra low attachment
plate
Sarah plate and we have we have followed
the changes that take place over a
number of hours the minority of the SS
that we have we are presenting today
they have been on they have been
performed over 20 hours of spirit growth
and those ferrets have been treated
throughout the presentation with the
model set of daxing compound it's a come
compound enormous cambogia case it is
not drug but it's a highly cytotoxic
compound and the reason why we have
chosen to utilize this company simply
because it is very very player tropic
compound so it has very many player
tropic effects so it affects so many of
different cellular functions that it's
really an excellent chemical pro and an
excellent chemical tool to be able to
study the impact and to be able to
interrogate the different cellular
functions are in 3d I want to show you
now what it looks like when we have
performed this Canada Commission of this
a five four nine farad so we have
visualized been using different kinds of
instruments we have utilized the Evo's M
7000 imaging system and we have also
utilized our thermo scientific imaging
platform the cell inside vx7 imaging
platform and you are going to be soon
watching a video that shows how so
over time structure and become over and
over more compact as time progresses so
it has been described that this is how
actually steroids get assembled but I
think it's very revealing when you
actually have the opportunity to follow
over time this exchanges that take place
and and we are going to show you quickly
now on this video I just want you to
bear in mind that as these cells become
more and more complex they also become
more resilient they also become more
chemo torrents two different kinds of
treatments and this is something that we
can see from from a quantitative point
of view latisha is going to be talking
over those points now but you can also
see it very nicely how they become so
complex over time with this imaging
system and now you're going to see
basically the resources you can the
images that you can obtain over a period
of forty eight hours with the cell
inside six seven imaging platform
you
and now from this point forward I leave
the floor to my colleague Leticia
Montoya so that you will continue to to
walk you through these different
examples of cell health as I said that
we presented earlier today
Thank You Larry for that introduction
now that we have talked about the
importance of 3d models and the
technology used to study 3d models we
will now talk about how several existing
reagents that are established for 2d
models can be used for studying 3d
models now cyclone X CD is an
established 2d model photometric cell
viability affray that is solution based
there are two components to this assay
xct which is a redox dye in PMS which is
an electron acceptor that enhances the
reduction of X 2 T so this FA is an ad
in read FA which means you can mix the
two components together and then add the
mixture to your treated or untreated
cells and incubate for 4 hours at 37
degrees after the incubation you measure
that absorbance at 450 and 660
nanometers now the greater your
absorbance value and your absorbance
response over time the more viable cells
you have as either you mentioned before
because this is a photometric
measurement on the various can Lux
microplate reader detection method is
through the well meaning that both your
2d and 3d model systems can be analyzed
the same way on the various chemical
microplate reader with the cyclone x CT
reagent
here we have a drug dose response
comparison of monolayer or 2d model
systems and steroids or 3d model systems
with this experiment monolayer of cells
or thirds were plated for 19 hours to
allow the cells to adhere to the bottom
of the well and to allow for type
spheroid formation both of these models
were then treated with gamboge ik acid
and cell viability was assessed with sai
Kwong x CT at different hours of drugs
incubation time so we looked at either 2
hours 19 hours or 48 hours of drug
treatment as shown within these graphs
as incubation time increases with
gamboge ik acid the drug becomes more
potent additionally when comparing
steroids and mono layers of cells
gamboge ik acid is less potent to
steroids n2 monolayer hours mono layers
of cells so as in this experiment cyclin
x ET was incubated on the cells for four
hours to establish a strong of build and
three doubts
and we can see the graphs here on the
left you have monolayer and on the right
you have spheroid
so here's a summary of the ic50 values
obtained from the cyclonic CT analysis
with the drug treatment of mono layer or
spheroid cellular models as I mentioned
earlier higher concentrations of gambar
check acid are required to kill the
19-hour steroids when compared to mono
lair cell or to the diverse structures
or cultures
so this is because of the complexity
complexity of the 3d models more of the
drug is required to penetrate the core
of the complex structure
now this is an example of this cycle on
xct as an endpoint
assay taking a read after four hours of
incubation with I climax CT so next we
will talk about using the cyclone x ET
sa in kinetic mode
the kinetic as a the reduction rate of
the cyclonic CP reagent was monitored
over time here we have untreated
monolayer of cells or drug treated
monolayer cells with the untreated mono
layer styles which is the blue line the
absorbance signal increases over time
and eventually plateaus at about five
hours this plateau is because all the
viable cells have been measured with the
cyclone xct reagents furthermore if you
look at the drug treatment it cells or
the dead cells which is the yellow line
the absorbance signal continues to
increase over time but slowly this is
why it is important to record the
background signal and the signal that
comes from your media only when treated
with a cyclonic CT reagent this
background signal that is obtained must
be subtracted from your test samples to
obtain a true signal from your viable
cells
now if we look at the reduction rate of
the cyclonic Ct reagent when incubated
on untreated steroids the blue line we
also see an increase in absorbance
signal however within 24 hours 24 hours
we still do not see the signal plateau
indicating that it takes longer for the
site context EP reagent to be reduced
one thing to keep in mind when studying
3d steroids is that they are compact as
opposed to a monolayer cells which are
very spread out this is important
because with this compact structure it
will take some time for the reagent to
enter the center of the compact
structure as similarly to the drug
treated monolayer cells the drug treated
spheroids presented presents a very low
signal turn on confirming the absence of
metabolically active so which is your
yellow line
now although the signal from the cyclone
xct reagent continues to increase over
time with the steroids
the potency values are very similar here
are we have a table with different
incubation times with the psych want XPT
reagent and the ic50 values obtained at
those incubation times and you can see
within this table the ic50 values are
within 32 high 30 micro molar range no
matter at what time you take a reading
with a cyclone xct reagent and because
of this the cyclone XE t cell viability
fa can be used for both endpoint and
kinetic as a mode
now only now not only can we quantify
the cell viability of series and
monolayers ourselves we can also
visualize the health of the spheres by
microscopy these images were obtained on
the eve of M 7000 imaging system on
either a flat-bottomed 96-well plate or
on the monolayers out for monolayer
cells or a nunc u bottom 96-well plate
for the steroids
from left to right we have high
concentrations of gamboge ik acid - low
concentrations of gamboge ik acids and
from top to bottom we have increasing
incubation time with a drug starting at
two hours down to 48 hours so if we look
at the top at the two hours of the drug
treatment we can see a tight compact
structure of these steroids like that of
untreated steroids which is associated
with high cell viability but as time
progresses with the drug treatment that
compact structure is lost which is seen
in the 48-hour images with the high drug
treatment at the bottom of this slide
as for the mono layer cells the cells
follow up and die at high concentrations
of drug which is different to the viable
spreading of cells so also keep in mind
the structure of your 2d and 3d cellular
models when you're looking at cell
viability
so we talked about a photometric cell
viability assay press the blue HS now
though is a fluorescent cell viability
assay press the blue HS where HS stands
for high sensitivity as a new and
improved viability Ave there are more
than 50% reduction in the background and
an increase in the signal to background
ratio when compared to the original
press the blue agent generally when
press the blue is used it's used for a
short time short incubation time press
the blue HS is an ad in reagent that can
be read in both absorbance and
fluorescence however we highly recommend
to use the fluorescence mode because of
the higher sensitivity now the main
component within press the blue HS is
recovering which gets reduced to
fluorescent reza roofin when in the
presence of viable living cells
because presto blue HS is a solution
based off a and the resolution product
gets released into the solution a top
reading is preferred for both mono layer
and both mono layer and spheroids of
cells top reading is best for
homogeneous solutions in the square
sense mode as mentioned by utterly ER in
this presentation
here we have another drug dose response
comparison of monolayer of cells and
steroids with this experiment again
monolayer cells or spheres are plated at
19 hours to allow the cells to adhere to
the bottom of the well and to also allow
for that tight compact structure of
steroids to form both models were then
treated with cambogia Cassatt and the
cell viability was assessed with press
the blue HS at different hours of drug
incubation time which is 2 hours 19
hours or 48 hours as shown within these
graphs as incubation time increases
again we see is that the gamboge ik acid
the drug beats the longer incubation
times with gamboge ik acid the drug
becomes more potent
so additionally when comparing spheroid
and monolayer cells gamboge ik acid is
less potent to series than to model a
ourselves the results are very similar
to what we saw earlier with a cyclone
xtt reagent
here's a summary of
50 values obtained from the press of
blue HS analysis with a drug treated
monolayer or thyroid model as I
mentioned earlier high concentrations of
gamboge ik acid are required to kill the
19 hours fear is when compared to mono
layer cells or 2d cultures now
specifically with mono layer cells there
is a time-dependent cytotoxic effect
from gamboge ik acid
so the mono layer cells die off faster
than your cells within your spheroid
structure
we can also look at press the blue HS in
kinetic mode we can monitor the
reduction rate of the cells with press
the blue HS over time which is shown in
this graph on this slide there is only
one thing to remember when using
pressable HS in kinetic mode reza roofin
can always over reduce to non
fluorescent dye hydro resolution which
is why at about our nine or ten with
this untreated monolayers it sells the
blue line in this graph the fluorescent
signal starts to decrease
if you incubate with press the blue HS
to long the dye hydro reza roofin will
be produced and you can obtain a false
negative the yellow line is indicative
of the absence of metabolically active
cells or drug treated monolayer cells
similarly with the psyche want xtt
reagent incubating untreated spheroids
the blue line whisper blue HS there is a
slow increase in signal over time the
reduction kinetics of pressable HS on
steroids is slower than that on the mono
layer cells again to the to the tight
compact structure itself and as
similarly to the drug treated monolayer
cells the drug treated spirits present a
very low signal turn on confirming the
absence of metabolically active cells
press the blue HS FA can be used for
both endpoint in genetic studies
psyphon direct is another fluorescence
assay that quantifies cellular
proliferation and viability and steigler
side of toxicity there are two different
components to the Cyclones direct FA
there's a nucleic acid I and a
background suppressor the nucleic acid
dye is live cell permeable and
concentrates to the nucleus of the cell
and the background suppressor is a cell
impermeable reagent that suppresses the
green background fluorescence these two
components work well together that there
there is no need for a wash step when
using them which makes this and this
assay very simplified
now because the fluorescence signal
accumulates within the nucleus of the
saddle a bottom rate is best for these
assays for both 2d and 3d cellular
models
using this icon direct si to evaluate
evaluate cell viability similar results
are obtained as we saw earlier with the
cyclone xct and press the blue HS a
similar experiment was done as I
mentioned before a monolayer silver
spirit were plated at 19 hours to allow
the cell to adhere to the bottom of the
well and your fear ear spheroid to form
both models were then treated with
gamboge ik acid and the cell viability
in this case was been assessed with a
cyclonic direct reagent at different
hours of drugs incubation time again two
hours 19 hours and 48 hours
as we saw previously with the other
reagent as incubation time increases
with the gamboge ik acid the drug
becomes more potent additionally when
comparing periods on the right and
monolayers on the Left gamboge ik acid
is less potent to the cell than to the
mono layer of cells
using psych want direct
as a ic50 values were then obtained for
the drug treated mono layer or spheroid
models the cytotoxicity of gamboge ik
acid on model errors versus spheroids is
consistent with the previous results
from our xct and press the blue HS
essays
now because one of the components of
this icon direct f8 is a background
suppressor that continues to enter the
slowly over time
sy Conte direct can only be used as an
endpoint FA as shown here with the
untreated monolayer cells the blue line
after about an hour of incubation with
sai Kwong direct the fluorescent signal
starts to drop and continues to drop
dramatically now there's a drop in
signal will provide a false negative
with drug treatment of monolayers of
cells this there is no signal of with
drug treatment of monolayer cells there
is no a little to no signal confirming
the absence of DNA after replicating
from replicating film
a similar decrease in fluorescent signal
is seen with untreated steroids as shown
in this graph with a blue line so we do
prefer that the psyche want direct assay
is used only as an endpoint mode for
both 2d and 3d sizer models we recommend
this so that you avoid obtaining that
false negative response
so far we have been talking about plate
reader microplate reader assays and all
those I quant direct is a micro plate
read FA one advantage of the psyche want
direct si is that it can be imaged as
well given that as a nucleic acid dye
and is most commonly used for high
content imaging experiments
so here I show that similar results for
cell viability using this icon Tareq can
be collecting using either the various
scan Lux microplate reader or the cell
insight HCA instruments the on the left
is the data collected on the various can
Lux microplate reader and on the right
is the data collected on the cell inside
cx-7 HCA platform because the HDI takes
and half hour or even longer to collect
data from a full 96-well plate and the
vero scan lux microplate reader only
takes a couple of minutes for obtaining
data on a full 96-well plate it would be
most beneficial to use the microplate
reader for initial screening before
moving on to in-depth complex imaging
experiments
so here I have a summary of the ic50
values obtained using psych want direct
as a cell viability a fate on drug
treated mono layer or spheroid models as
I mentioned earlier similar results and
similar ic50 values are obtained on
either the various can Lux microplate
reader or on the high content cx-7 HCA
platform so why use a time consuming
complex system like the HCA when you can
use a simplified workflow on the very
weekend looks microplate reader
the only advantage of using the
high-content dx7 platform is that you
can visualize the structure of the
spheroid
and when using this I want direct as a
cell viability at the your viable cells
become highly fluorescence now the top
row of images here are phase contrast
which allow you to visualize and see the
compact structure of the spheroid the
bottom row images are the fluorescent
channel for the psyche want direct
reagent labeling viable cells when these
images with these images you can see how
they pair with one another and how the
tight core of the spheroid decreases
from right to left as the drug
concentration increases and the cell
viability decreases
additionally the untreated and complex
structure is labeled with a psycho and
direct dye meaning that those cells
contain DNA and our cells that are
replicating
here's a summary table of all the
reagents we talked about today in this
webinar and their effect on 2d and 3d
cellular model systems no matter what
cell viability assay was used somewhere
I see 50 values were obtained at the
different drug incubation times either 2
hours 19 hours or 48 hours and across
the board we saw that as incubation time
increases with gamboge Icaza the drug
becomes more potent additionally when
comparing your spheroids and monolayers
cells gamboge ik acid is less potent and
spheroids to steroids than to modeling
ourselves
now I will hand off the presentation
back to my colleague Ari Ari
Thank You latisha well I really hope
that we have been able to demonstrate to
you guys the suitability of these three
essays for this comparative studies
between 2d and 3d or even for just
studying or integrating solo have
functions in 3d cells here you can see a
summary of the different issues that
were discussed by latisha we try to
cover all the possible measurements in
terms of detection technology so you had
photometric essays in the case of
cyclones xct and then we had two person
essays that can be read with top or
bottom reading in the case of press
relations with stop reading and
indicates of saikhan direct with bottom
reading all of the treatise as Leticia
explained in detail they can be used for
endpoint measurements but on the case of
kinetic measurements we recommend to use
only cyclones xev and press the blue
edges
psych 1 direct we recommend to use only
as important measurements they all are
having this kind of atom feed format so
they require really minimal effort
during the workflow and they have very
similar equation times with the dice and
in the case of multiplexing compact
compatibility then obviously the
personalities are superior and if you
are planning to to utilize different
readouts and combine different end
points different similar functions
integrate different functions and
obviously utilizing breadth of blue
ashes and cyclone direct even the two of
them together would be a better choice
from the perspective of doing orthogonal
research and combining these
quantitative faces with a machine then
the best choice here is its release icon
direct you you saw the really
spectacular images that you can obtain
with cyclone direct and the benefits
that then you can combine is
quantitative data and correlate with the
images that with these really nice
phenotypic as images that can be
obtained so we hope that you have
hopefully learn few essential issues
that needs to be taken into account
why
and utilizing this cell health essays
with micro page readers for us it's
really important to convey the idea that
we have a number of self-help microplate
as I said even though they were
originally developed for 2d sales models
they can be used for 3d 3dd spirits and
they really are a time and cost
efficient approach to assess therapeutic
effects of investigational compounds in
early drug discovery we have collected
here some of the resources that are
available for you are on our webpages we
have recently published an application
note that covers a number of tips and
tricks that can be used for performing
hydro boot fluorescent imaging and
analyzes of spirits and that application
note I think we recommended that's
really good to four to start and to know
how to approach this transition between
2d and 3d in that application note we
have a list of 12 reagents or essays
that we currently have shown to be
effective tools also in 3d using
different detection platforms that you
can see are listed here
so this hopefully will give you a quite
good guideline and it will really help
you navigate this transition between 2d
and 3d and also it will help you perform
in this comparison studies that we will
show you today so we hope that you have
been able to follow us through and that
you have to learn during this hour and
now we have time for taking your
questions and we really thank you for
your attention and we'll be happy to
answer any questions and those that we
cannot follow up then we happy to follow
up by email thank you
Thank You Ana re and Leticia for your
informative presentations we would love
to understand your practices in this
field you will now see a survey pop up
on your screen we appreciate your
participation
okay we will now move on to the live Q&A
portion of the webinar if you have a
question you'd like to ask please do so
now just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many questions as we
have time for alright let's get started
our first question is can you comment on
how luminescence measurements for 3d
cells performs of plate readers
you
thanks Michelle um this is a quite
interesting question we haven't we
didn't have the time to get into
luminous measurements but generally
speaking luminescence measurements with
pledged readers are always performed
from the top of the place so instruments
try to collect all the light that is
emitted in the main essence reactions so
there are really no no basic differences
between collecting light in 2d versions
3d systems so in that sense the show is
it has to do more with the SA than with
the way in which the light is collected
in my prepared readers
you
thank you
next question can the cell viability
reagent presented be used with 3d models
grown in them extra gel
question we get that question very often
so add and read solutions or adding read
solution based assays such as like press
the blue HS or Almar blue HS and cyclone
xtt which we presented here in the
webinar they can be used for 3d models
but the incubation times will have to be
optimized so you generally have to
incubate longer than you would with 3d
structures not inmate Rogell but keep in
mind such as SI such as sai Kwong lb h
which is where you have to remove the
solution from yourself into a brand new
plate in this case the LD h fa cannot be
used for 3d models it surrounded by
maître gel just because of that removal
of the media
great thank you okay next question
how can I make sure that the
fluorescence or luminescence values that
are measured with two different micro
plate readers are comparable
that's a great question and this is a
question that that we get asked very
very often so I think it's really
important to remember that florescent
and the Monessen measurements are always
relative measurements so they are going
to change from one micrometer to the
next one
what when if you are changing between
microliters and you want to make sure
that you are getting the same
performance from one might of a
microwave into the next one you have to
be able to always to measure the ratio
between the signal and the background so
that ratio should remain constant if you
are comparing different micro visitors
that have similar performance so that is
the one thing that you have to keep in
mind you cannot compare directly between
mic one microplate reader readout and
another one sometimes scaling sizes are
you so that numbers are larger numbers
are smaller so just bear in mind that
the range between the signal on the
background on your essence should remain
the same if you are performing the same
if you are reading the same place
between different micro procedures with
similar performance
right thank you okay next question how
much is the farad size a limiting factor
for these assays
you
that's another great question so the
steroid size is dependent on the type of
plate that you use you can have a we
recommend that you start with a
low-density plating all the way to a
high-density plating and determine at
what is the optimal size for your serie
that you're actually using and how long
of that drug incubation time to use but
not only that but also how long the
reagent to incubate with so it's not
necessarily a limiting the limiting
factor is how sensitive your reagent is
so it kind of goes back to your reagent
and how sensitive it can detect a number
of cells
thank you next question how do you
measure a background signal
um I can answer that so background
signal is always measured on the media
on the buffer that you are actually
performing your essay and it should of
course I have the data included on that
on that media or buffer this is really
important because for example if you are
running essays on fan of let's
containing media phenol red is known to
absorb light at very common excitation
wavelengths so this is something that
you have to be aware of and I didn't
have time to get into that but this is
one reason as to why cell based systems
are actually often one of these are
often measure from the bottom because
then it can you can you can exclude the
effect of phenol red but the way that
you can establish the background levels
it's always with the with them with the
solvent that you're using media buffer
and then of course having the the
contribution of the dye in the absence
of cells in this case
you
thank you what's the largest size of
steroids that can be assayed
goes back to the question we had earlier
of your reagent itself and so the more
cells that you have the longer
incubation time you're going to have
year with your reagent but it also goes
back to the size of plate so we bran see
right as high as 10,000 cells per well
but those were with again a 5 or 9 cells
or lung cancer cells if you have a
smaller cell type such as
mcf7 you can actually have more within
your wealth you can have 20,000 per well
so the size really is based off of your
size of cell and then the reagent itself
again you either have to have a longer
incubation time for larger steroids or
you can shrink that incubation time if
you go down to say 500 cells so a
smaller sample size
you
you
any other questions Michelle
we have time for one more question if
one is only studying 3d cells and not
comparing with 2d models is top
fluorescence enough to quantify for
essence signals on steroids
yeah another really good question in the
minority of the SI said we have tested
top right and it's pretty sufficient to
to to measure frozen signal on steroids
on this model that we discussed you in
the webinar but but it would need to be
optimized and it would need to be
compared it's very very strongly
dependent on the type of I say that
you're utilizing on the double vision as
latisha has mentioned several time so
you would not need to be optimized but
yes as a general rule you would say that
top-top fluorescent might be sufficient
for a good marriage good good portion of
the essays out there
thank you our Aryan Leticia for your
time today and your important research
we would also like to thank lab roots
and our sponsor Thermo Fisher Scientific
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go I'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions any
questions we did not have time for today
and those Derk those submitted during
the on-demand period will be addressed
by the speakers via the contact
information you provided at the time of
registration this webcast can be viewed
on-demand laberd's full alert you via
email when it's available for replay we
encourage you to share that email with
your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event until next time
goodbye